the rate of increase of interest rates
been so
fast um and it's so rapid the question
now is also being how does the FED cut
its interest rate and what volume does
it cut its interest rate is it going to
is it going to be significant chunks at
a time or is it going to be gradual I'm
of the belief that it will be
significant chunks uh rather than
smaller 25% basis points uh drops I
think it's going to be more more likely
75 um 50 75 if not even 100 basis point
drops all right guys bang bang I've got
Oliver here with me uh I thought a great
place to start is tration wants to build
a better measurement of inflation that
is probably the the high level uh kind
of mission but first we got talk about
the old method uh it is pretty well
understood across Wall Street across
macroeconomy uh across Market
participants the inflation metric is the
best we got CPI uh a lot of questions a
lot of controversies a lot of debate how
do you all think about what is good
about CPI and and the data collection
and methodology and then where are the
areas where maybe they're lacking or
could be improved yeah so first of all
thanks for having me on um I let me go
through it the BLS uh which is the
official Bureau of Labor Statistics
which is the government measurement tool
of inflation um is measured by doing
roughly I think it's 880,000 interviews
on a monthly basis where they go and
either do store checks to check prices
or they have a survey that goes out but
eventually they ask households what are
the price points of these particular
items um and I think the great thing is
it's been going on for so long um that
it gives you a very nice longitudinal
Trend the the downside with for that
history of having all that time series
analysis that you can do with that data
set is that of course that you're bound
by the lack the the the constraints of
innovation of this type of of a data set
um and so the way true inflation started
approaching it was like we got to find a
way how to update and modernize this
this
capability um and of course you if you
think back to the BLS when it first
started it was pre first world war it's
more than a hundred years old and if you
think about it what's the real Evolution
that's been there not that dramatic and
since then you know we've also you know
not only had the consumer boom of the
70s and ' 80s
we've had the whole internet bubble of
online shopping e-commerce and all
that's changed how to measure inflation
as what it was done historically and I
think that's that has allowed us to
modernize it in our own way that what we
believe is the right way to go forward
to measuring inflation as
comprehensively as one possibly can now
let's talk about how you guys actually
are doing it differently there's like
data collection and then there's the
methodology or the calculation maybe
start first with data collection what
are you using different data points or
you have some of methodology do you have
just way more people going into the
stores how does it
work yeah we don't actually send people
into the stores uh we collect data from
about 40 different data sources um and
they all those data sources aggregate up
to about 18 million price points of
goods and services on a daily weekly
monthly basis um so we aggregate all
that data set into 12 product categories
ranging from things like food and
beverages all the way through to housing
transp ation Recreation and culture
Education Health and so forth and we
measure each of those indexes on a daily
basis and I think that the the key
fundamental difference for us has always
been not only the volume of data that
we're dealing with but I think most more
importantly is the frequency which
allows for a much more analytical
capability by having many more Trend
points along the way yes by having daily
you get a lot more uh noise and
variability but it gives you a
considerably greater uh Trend ability
and forecastability applications rather
than having one dot per month now when
you start looking at the calculation and
methodology if you're getting let's say
more robust data better data uh you
could still screw up the methodology you
could be just as wrong as anyone else or
um or not like how do you think about
the the calculation being uh maybe more
accurate or more
advanced yeah I think the calculation is
more comprehensive as a result of having
the volume of data that we have the
robustness as you mentioned um and I
think that's for a number of reasons is
that we don't need to put in separate
calculations in there for for people
downgrading or upgrading or um new
materials coming into clothing therefore
the price point changes we don't need to
reflect those and some some the BLS and
others uh use things like the Fisher
Index to look at Cost of Living
adjustments you also have the pass index
which looks at this down trading up
trading um and all these different types
of of of calculations that are sitting
on top of the index means that you're
adding in our
view you're adding a a potential error
on top of a data set on top of a a
calculation that's sitting on top of
another calculation on top of another
calculation but at the root C of cause
of everything is this 80,000 sample
interview that they do to collect price
price points of goods and services and I
think that's the fundamental thing is
the volume of data allows us to remove
these additional calculations that other
organizations have because we're
measuring not only prices but we're also
seeing volumetric data set coming in
which gives us this consumer
understanding whe the downgrading
upgrading without having to create an
additional calculation for that now as
we look at a better calculation with
more robust data one of the questions
becomes would the Federal Reserve or
other people in the economy actually
make better decisions like if we had a
different but better measurement how
much would it change decision-making
what what are the things that would be
different if this became the standard uh
kind of measurement that everyone looked
at yeah look I mean at the end of the
day we're we're trying to True flation
is trying to measure um inflation in the
most comprehensive manner possible right
and our goal is to is to is to achieve
that um and I think it we're a long way
off from there there's a lot more that
we can do but I think we given the
volume of data sets that we're dealing
with the frequency of data sets that
we've got I think it it does
alternatively change Market Outlook so
if we look you know where our
predictability as a result of our data
has been of the BLS for example where we
try and match our data to the BLS and
predict what their numbers are you know
we've got a really comprehensive uh you
know forecasting capabilities you know
we're on an average month we for the
last year and a half I think that we've
been doing this we've only got a
variability of
0.14% right and that's better than when
Bloomberg is it's better than the
average of 40 different economists that
we track so you know that gives us
better forecast ability I think that's
one aspect of it um do we see our data
being a replacement of the BLS by
organizations look that's up to each of
our clients and organizations to predict
I think what we we tend to position
ourselves as an alternative data set at
least in the interim so that they can
start using our data seeing the value of
it and then in due course um people
might choose to replace data sets Al
together but I think in the initial term
we see it very much as an alternative
data set which gives you another
triangulation of what the likely Trends
are in the
marketplace talk to me about who are the
types of people using this are these
macro fund you know kind of uh hedge
fund Traders are these uh economists
who's actually consuming the data and
what are they doing with it this episode
is brought to you by aradine they are a
brand new startup led by a number of
Silicon Valley Legends who just raised
$81 million to build the future of
Internet infrastructure you're probably
wondering what that means let me explain
there are numerous new disruptive
technologies that are being adopted
simultaneously from blockchain to
artificial intelligence to zero
knowledge Technologies in order to
ensure that these Technologies thrive in
this new world we need new
infrastructure and that is where arine
comes in they just launched their first
product line called Tera flux which is a
Bitcoin minor powered by the world's
first 4 nanometer silicon chip
technology these air cools singlephase
and dual phase emerging cooling miners
have unrivaled speed and efficiency
theyve Superior uptime and they leverage
a brand new innovation called Energy
tune that allows miners to dynamically
adjust the energy consumption and
Bitcoin hash rate based on demand
response needs of the electrical grids
aradine is an ambitious company working
on hard problems I'm really impressed
with them and if you want to check out
more you can go to idine.com that's a r
a d i ne.com
go check them out at idine.com
today yes so you got uh it ranges quite
quite broadly uh much broader than we
initially thought where we launched the
capability um so at one end you got
macro uh uh people that are very
interested in just looking at what our
forecast is for the next three months
six months what are some of the
structural foundations that we're
looking in within the inflationary
numbers that could point to a different
Trend in the for in the long term um
then you get the Quant guys um who are
looking at to adjust their their trading
strategies and how they adjust uh their
investment investment decisions and then
you got people who are producing even in
the defi world who are producing
Products off our data uh for you know
real world assets for example people are
creating inflation protected stable
coins or flat coins you're getting
people looking at trying to use our data
to um you know tokenized oil data then
added inflationary protection oil data
on top of that so all these variabil
ities of data sets that we actually
partially knew but partially didn't sort
of expect the volume of growth that to
come on has been phenomenal so those the
broadly aspecting are the various types
of users in our data sets now one of the
things that's interesting is if you
spend all day trying to figure out how
to build a great product that can
collect data can calculate and use the
methodology to have this alternative
data set you eventually have to have a
personal opinion in terms of what's
going to happen with uh inflation right
like you can't just stare the data along
like I have no clue
um and so one of the things that's
interesting to me is uh I get uh maybe
it's daily or weekly email from you guys
and it's different kind of thought
processes of hey this is something to
pay attention to this something we're
seeing in the data this is something
that we think is going to happen one of
those emails recently talked about
sticky inflation in 2024 uh that is
somewhat against the narrative there's
many people who think the FED is winning
the fight and inflation is going to wave
the White Flag it's over the fed's going
to win and let's move on with their life
are they wrong why do you guys think
that inflation is going to continue to
be sticky
yeah so we have we certainly believe
inflation is going to be a little more
stickier Than People expect um I think
the shortterm outlook for the remaining
part of this year coming into the q1
next year um you know we sort of see a
bit of a a rise again the back maybe
December in January um in inflation
numbers not a massive jump where we are
but it's sort of upper trajectory and
then it'll slowly come down again I
think there are you know I think there
are three
longer
term longer term outlooks that I think
we need to understand before we can
really deal with inflation and those are
the structural elements and one of them
is you know the government's investing a
lot of money to onshore capability look
at the semiconductor uh elements
Investments That government's doing
you're looking at the green energy
Investments the government doing all
that is bringing capabilities back on
Shore and using fantastically using US
Labor and but that's all increase cost
from where they are produced today right
and so that cost structure is going to
be passed on to the consumer at some
point or or at some point that's one
aspect of it the second aspect of it is
this removal of the middle class right
you look at the variability of the last
10 15 20 30 years the metal class the
middle class has been eroding and the
bulk of that middle class has actually
been um been either well the bulk of has
been dropping down into
sort of a lower income base but there
are individuals that are going up in the
higher income and the higher income are
just spending and that's fueling again
more growth and more uh more spending
power therefore more pricing power
that's coming into the market I think
the third thing why we think that
inflation is going to be a lot more
sticky is it g to be less in less
innovation in the marketplace because
the cost of capital is high and that
cost of capital then is then you know
where you going to get productivity
gains how much is the AI going to impact
that if the capital injection money
flowing into organizations is gonna is
going to benefit through there and I
think finally within that you know I I
don't I don't believe I'm not a I'm an
average promoter and believer of AI but
I don't believe the impact of AI is
going to be instantaneously and I think
that's going to be a much longer Outlook
about three maybe four years before
corporations start to really see the
long-term gains of productivity gains
from AI so I think those are some of the
structural elements that need to be
addressed I think in the short term
where we feel that things are be a lot
more stickier I think is going to be in
the service based economies service
based Goods as sorry service based
prices with unemployment Market you look
at the jobless claims most recently been
holding relatively stable the continu
jobless claims have been rising up a bit
the last couple of weeks it's coming
down again recently I think you holding
interesting about the unemployment
number comes out with but that's been
relatively stable it's softening a bit
but not too much so and wage inflations
are still quite quite high so although
it's coming down it's still quite strong
so I think that whole service bucket is
going to be a key Focus for the FED to
look into to see what decision base they
come out with um I think that on the
flip side you've also got the housing
market right and housing is one of the
biggest contributors to household income
household expenditure and I think the
housing market in the US is restricted
by significant Supply right I think
volumes the sales of housing has dropped
that's clear no one's disputing that I
think that's caused by you know the
increased mortgage rates uh the interest
rates as a result of that I think you
know there's also the fact the lack of
movement of Labor and talent across the
country we've seen previously um and I
think all this work from home and this
new working environment is causing less
movement of Labor as well and I think
somewhere that lack of Supply the lack
of restriction of housing is going to
keep those prices relatively strong in
the short term at in the longer term
that will slowly start to come down and
reverse the trends but at least in the
interim that I we don't see a Viewpoint
of our opinion that that's going to come
down in the near in the near
future as we see AI continue to permeate
throughout the society economy Etc how
much of AI is just like a reinforcement
of the deflationary effects and that
actually gives more Runway to the fed
and others for loose monetary policy and
and kind of like hey our big worry
should be deflation not high inflation
because AI is going to be this dominant
thing yeah I think I you know look I'm
of the I mean we use AI like crazy in
our in our organization and and we love
it right um but as I said I I think that
the timing of when AI is really adopted
at a mass scale that produces the
productivity gains that everyone is
expecting I I don't see that in the
immediate Horizon I think you that much
more in the longer term and so therefore
the FED is probably in our view probably
looking at that more as a longer term
Outlook and like coming back to that
structural element changes that's coming
on on board I think I think in the in
the more shorter term the fed's going to
be focused on things like core inflation
going to be focused on services and
they're going to be focused on you know
gas prices right if OPEC can can proceed
with their desires of Saudi Arabia and
Russia looking trying to restrict uh
OPEC production and what's going on in
in Israel versus Hamas and the war there
I think there is a lot of a lot of
opportunity or
a lot of concern for the FED to maintain
their PR their interest rates at a at a
higher level for longer because if if
oil prices go up that affects so many
product categories that we that we use
on a daily basis whether it's you know
50% of the oil prices at the pump at the
oil prices follow through right down to
the pump but then affects all the whole
raft of other product categories and
services right so I think it's the
shorter term Outlook is where the FED
will be uh concerned about for the next
three to six months and their Outlook
Horizon there I think the services
element is going to be a critical factor
for them and see if that starts to
soften I think they'll start to see uh a
bit of a maybe a loosening of their
viewpoints of of of interest rates and
maybe that start coming down a bit
earlier than expected I think the other
thing to think in effect is the the rate
of the rate of increase of interest
rates been so
fast um and it's so rapid the question
now is also being how does the FED cut
its interest rate in what volume does it
cut its interest rate is it going to is
it going to be significant chunks at a
time or is it going to be gradual I'm of
the belief that it will be significant
chunks uh rather than smaller 25% basis
points uh drops I think it's going to be
more more likely
75 um 50 75 if not even 100 basis point
drops why do you think that why why do
you think it's going to be so
aggressive I I just think if you start
looking at economic data and if you
start looking at the level of which
they've accelerated to and if there is a
softening in the economic data sets
that's coming through in q1 early late
q1 um you know no one's expect I mean
the the GDP forecast in quarter three
was at
4.9% uh you know you like that's it's
obviously anomaly in the grand scheme of
things everyone's expecting the Q Q4
number to come down again um but still
it's still going to be it's going to be
a strong number at least the forecast s
and I think somewhere once the the
numbers start to soften a bit and if if
the I don't know the prices of goods and
services start to see some softening
then I think they'll start to drop it
and because of the level they're at it's
going to come down more dramatic than
otherwise and so that's why I think it's
going to be much more of a dramatic
chunks of decline rather than a gradual
25 basis drops at a time
got it now when we start to look at
maybe um other areas of the economy in
terms of uh inflation one of the things
I always remind people is when prices go
up they don't come back down I don't see
any of the restaurants cutting their
prices back I don't see you know a
number of these things that that all
went up um how do you think about uh
trying to incorporate you know that
level it's almost more like cost of
living uh and the persistent rise of
that over time uh more so than it is
just a true like year-over-year
inflation
number yeah if we go back I mean this is
the this is the thing that we've been
reporting on for quite a while true
inflation which is to say if we went
back to before the inflationary
increases started occurring so back down
to 2020 for example people have had you
know 20% of their money has been eroded
right and varying income groups that
varies but more than 20% of your income
has been eroded because of inflation and
that number is not going to come down
right it's it's the rate of increase
will slow down that is clear um but
we're not expecting I maybe one or two c
will expect we expect real deflation but
again it's real deflation versus last
year or versus a year ago it's not real
deflation back to you know three two
three years ago where we've had this
massive surge of 20% 25% increases of
erosion of people's uh exp uh income and
therefore purchasing power and I think
that's that's the real fundamental thing
and I don't see us going back down to
those levels in any man of shape or
form now when we see the consumer
obviously they feel inflation they
complain about things being expensive
but I think if you walked down the
street most people couldn't tell you
what the inflation number is itself how
do you see their behaviors actually
changing in terms of uh these high
inflation environments and is there some
sort of psychological scarring that
occurs where the high inflation that we
experienced over the last couple of
years will change behavior that even
when inflation gets back under control
these people will continue to uh kind of
act the same way as if inflation was
still closer to 10% this episode is
brought to you by c.com what do I have
in common with Chad Hurley from YouTube
Toby from Shopify and Alexis from 776
and the co-founder of Reddit we all use
cal.com instead of cly and we are all
early investors as well cal.com is
leading the charge of scheduling
Platforms in the open-source sphere
offering you the chance to harness the
efficiency previously reserved for leite
corporations and Tech gurus if you like
to have your calendar organized and be
able to have an efficient exchange when
scheduling
but you love all of the benefits of
open- source technology then cal.com is
for you they are transforming
sophisticated calendar management into
an accessible tool for all via a
userfriendly interface you can customize
it and you can make your calendar work
for you use code pomp for $500 off when
you set up your team with cal.com today
again go to cal.com
cal.com and use code pomp to get $500
off when you sign up cal.com an open
source tool to that allows you to take
back control of your calendar be
efficient when scheduling and make sure
that no one can steal your time yeah
that's actually an interesting question
for us because we've been actually doing
some we're starting to do some quite
deep analysis into that right now we're
trying to understand what what are the
trigger points of when we'll start to
see a real change and one of the factors
we're looking at of course is um is
consumer expenditure or consumer
purchasing power consumer spending
levels and if you look at all those
variables that are out there for a form
of metric of consumer spending um they
haven't really slowed down right um
there's postco we saw huge government
stimulus packages coming in to uh bulk
up people's expenditure patterns they
spent more um the savings rate went up
they couldn't go out then they had
Revenge spending and that all came back
and now we're people are came out the
summer had huge retail sales uh yes it's
marketly come down a bit uh this month
but a huge significant retail sales in
September um and I think somewhere you
know the question for us is to say is
how are people funding that the
expenditure per happens and we're seeing
saving rates being ered eroded we're
seeing um uh debt levels increasing
whether it's household debt from a
mortgage perspective whether it's credit
card debt um you got all these other
debt factors that people are dealing
with whether it's order loans whether
it's loans and so forth and they've only
been increasing at a household level and
So you you're starting to see okay well
savings is eroding and household uh debt
levels increasing I've got higher
interest rates to refinance that debt so
you know that's the sort of correlation
that we've been looking into and one of
the things that we're looking into now
is that saying well if you look at an a
if there's lack of mobility and people
are not moving around the country not
buying new homes because of the higher
interest rates and people and the O
owner occupancy rates are very high in
the US so therefore people are most
likely not going to be switching out
from their 30-year fixed mortgages to
get anything else and their purchasing
power is still relatively strong unlike
if you look in other markets like in
Europe where the variability of that
mortgage rate changes every five years I
mean it's you don't have a 10 to 30 year
fixed in other markets very few other
markets have that and so that gives it
the US that takes a bit of a longer
longer time for that impact of an
erosion of consumer expenditure to
change behavior and we see that most
likely to come in probably sometime in
the end of q1 Q2 next year if things
hold as they as we expect them to hold
but we'll get more up to date to that
once we start finishing on modeling talk
to me about the product itself in terms
of um how do people interface with you
all how much of this is API versus more
like uh dashboard type stuff what are
you seeing from actual customer usage
yeah so so we got three trl's got three
basic platforms you either go on the
dashboard you look at the at the uh
website and you can access all the data
that's there you can see that you can
also go there and consumers a retail
investor you can go and and and and
purchase the data or you can get the
access data through an API with the
forecast ability with matching into uh
into the BLS data sets if people want
that we have our our our Economist teams
and our analyst teams coming together
with clients one-on-one to to debrief
the Outlook of the future why it's
happening uh what our forecasts are what
our three month rolling forecasts are
and so forth so those are the generally
three platforms you either got an
Enterprise solution at one end or you
got the dashboard access on the website
on the other end now what are some of
the challenges that you guys are facing
right now from a pure product standpoint
so not data collection not kind of the
methodology but what what are some of
the things you're thinking about with
user experience or how you'd be able to
actually make this much more uh kind of
um uh prevalent AC across Wall Street
and elsewhere yeah I think for us is one
I think first of all the exposure of our
data set I think it's fairly well known
uh of course there's more work for us to
be doing to accelerate exposure um but I
think the other factor for us is how do
we drive more defined usability of the
data right you know especially now in a
world where we believe inflation is
going to be hanging around a lot more a
lot longer than than the market is
expecting um but how do we translate
that into additional models forecasting
know we start doing now casting with
every new data injection that we get you
know how do we leverage that into um
models and and Quant aspects for for end
users right and that creates for us um
you know a bit more of a stickier
relationship and a bit more of a deeper
understanding with the community of what
they're asking for versus what we can
deliver so it's more trying to go deeper
into the data set more trying to find
deeper and support supporting the
analysis and applications that our end
users are using the data for um and and
I think that combination is where our
focus is right
now what's been the most surprising
thing to you in terms of doing this has
it been the receptivity maybe the
resistance from people maybe something
with the product what's really been
surprising um yeah I mean look we we I
think we were very fortunate around the
timing of our launch let's be clear
about that we launched uh nearly two
years ago and that the timing was you
know
spoton um and I think that blew up the
receptivity of it you know the amount of
monthly uh monthly users we're getting
on the site is incredible right and um
and the fact that there are you know
Bloomberg chat groups about true
infation dates I think is is amazing um
and so I think you know the receptivity
blew us blew us quite considerably I
think that on the flip side where we've
been desperately trying to keep up with
the high demand um is about how do
we provide the data in the most usable
format to be able to D dig be able for
consumers to digest the data as much as
they possibly can and so it's keeping up
with the usability of it it's keeping up
with a volume of data can we find other
data sets can we find things that
explain the movement of inflation so
what's the housing Supply what's
building material cost for example um
all these type of aspects is where we've
been focused that's that's been the flip
side of it is getting the demand to
drive that as much as we possibly can
with the resources that we've
got now what does success look like in
terms of 20 years from now true
inflation is quotequote successful does
it replace BLS is it just the best
alternative resource is there a bunch of
financial products that are built off of
this like like how do you think about
success for the product
itself yes I think look that there are
multiple prongs for success for us one
is um
how do we get more into products
especially in the defi world and but
also in the traditional Finance world so
how do we get our data in ingrained in
products and developments that's
happening around that's one aspect of it
I think the tokenization ability
certainly plays plays very nicely into
our data set um I think the second
aspect of it yes is that the data
becomes uh in due course not overnight
but I think in due course becomes the
gold standard for inflation
that is our aim that's what we've always
been designed to do um and we certainly
hope the market will follow us uh on a
journey to achieve that over a period of
time it's it's we're going to need more
credibility we're going have to get
people to become more familiar with the
data and so forth but yes that's very
much the longer term application I think
the third thing for us is then also not
only trying to get a gold standard and
also becoming more ingrained in products
but I think also is you know driv ding
the applications the the analytics of
the data how do we how do we customize
this a lot more how do we become more
bespoke and and apply all the data
requirements that everyone wants to do
and that's going to require not only
getting the analytical and using AI a
lot more than what we already are using
them today but more also data sets what
other data sets can we build into this
that is that's far reaching and then
become you know potentially a
marketplace where people buy and trade
and create custom index off our data
sets by combining I don't know oil
Commodities with inflation data or you
know wheat production with temperature
and rain data in Arkansas versus the
price of of carbs in grocery retailing
for example so you know the applications
that's sort of where we're looking at
where that future becomes sucess looks
like from a three- approach makes
complete sense to me where can we send
people to find you on the internet or
find out more about true
flation yeah we're got you can go to
true.com you'll find the websites there
contact us is on there if you need
anything from us you can go to our
telegram account or you can go to our
Twitter account both true flation um or
you can go to our LinkedIn account um
but yeah any questions we welcome any
ideas suggestions love to hear from
everybody awesome well I appreciate it
very much Oliver it's been fantastic I
always learn something we talk and I
think people will learn from this
conversation as well so we'll definitely
do it again in the future thanks a lot
for having me Anthony been great
conversation